[Music]
[Applause]
We Make Way for uh Dean blandino the Fox
NFL rules analyst former vice president
of NFL officiating joining us on the
program good to see you again let me
start at the line of scrimmage in that
moment with cadarius Tony and the role
that the official plays when he sees
that Tony is off
Sid so you see this throughout the game
and and so line of scrimmage officials
receivers there's that communication a
lot of it nonverbal the receiver will
look to the official the official will
make sure the receiver understands where
the line of scrimmage is and a lot of it
is I'm a receiver I know I have to be
off the line of scrimmage or on the line
of scrimmage so I look to the official
the official shows me with their leg
their foot their front foot here's the
line of scrimmage and you can line up
accordingly and so in a situation like
that you're going to have that non
verble communication but when you're
lining up offside and is as blatant as
it was and as obvious as it was you know
early in the game if it's close marginal
you'll warn the player but in a
situation like that when you're that
offside you're going to get the call
whether it's in the first quarter or the
fourth quarter what if Tony looks to the
official and ask for help in that
moment yeah and the official should give
that give that help to that player and I
I've seen some video you know online
where there's there there's one shot I
don't know where the camera came from
but looks like Tony quickly looks to the
sideline that is so fast there's no way
that he could have gotten any
acknowledgement from the official with
just a quick cursory glance over there
typically you'll see that with the
receivers that are closer to the
sideline and they'll look they may even
adjust their position based on what the
official you know what they're getting
from the official but the official will
give that help if the help is you know
is asked for well I mentioned this that
the official doesn't want to make that
call I mean it's an incredible play you
don't want to be the story and that's
why you know Mahomes and Andy Reid were
so upset that the officials and you know
they make mistakes and you know they're
going to be fine for the comments that
they made but an official I don't think
goes man I haven't I haven't thrown a
flag in a while I'd like to get a little
airtime here no no and ESP line of
scrimmage official you're not even
getting the air time you're giving the
referee the air time cuz you don't even
get to make the announce ment but the
thing is a a foul like that that's a
foul at the snap the official throws the
flag immediately once the ball is
snapped they have no idea that this is
going to be an incredible play with
Travis Kelce throwing the ball back to
Tony they just see what they see they
see a violation they throw the flag they
officiate the rest of the play I think
all of those factors just led to this
being controversial because if that's
just an incomplete pass it's not this
it's not this gigantic thing that we're
all still talking about was this a point
of emphasis for officials this year it
it was you know when you look at
offensive offside that is not a call
that had been made going into this
season very often from 2015 to 2022 the
all of those years there was only 14
across the entire league this year with
the Tony penalty there's already been 13
and this to me comes from the tush push
the brotherly shove that play the offici
department has really put an emphasis on
officiating the line of scrimmage more
closely with players on and offs side
and I think we've seen that now it's
bled over to these other areas that are
not tush push plays but we're seeing
like I said 13 in one year compared to
the eight previous years they're only
being 14 total it's it's clearly a point
of emphasis explain to me and we saw
this with the Chiefs opening night where
their tackles seem like they were back
further it's almost as if the NFL was
trying trying to give them a little bit
of a head start to help against these
Edge rushers who are clearly more
athletic than them uh is that a point of
emphasis to allow the tackles to be back
a little bit more than maybe they should
be and they're not on the line of
scrimmage they're not you want watch the
play with Tony look at the right tackle
look at Taylor on that play he's he's so
far back and they're both supposed to be
on the line of scrimmage so I think that
that has been less emphasized it started
right remember Lions Chiefs opening
night we had the whole whole thing with
Taylor not lining up on the line of
scrimmage so I think we are seeing less
less restrictive in that area and like
you said that's a key thing when you
talk about the offensive line versus the
defensive line the defensive line is
winning more often than not scoring is
down passing yards are down so you're
going to give those tackles I think the
league is making that you know known to
the officials don't be overly technical
Let The Tackle have a little bit of that
head start but again you've got that
part part of it and now you're
officiating the other part being on the
line for receivers and other players to
tush push play more closely and I think
that's where teams sometimes struggle
with the consistency we're talking to
Dean blandino Fox NFL rules analyst
former vice president of NFL officiating
what um what's your biggest concern with
officiating I mean I let me tell you
mine and that is it has to do with
gambling so when there is a a call that
it's not just fan emotion now there's
money at stake here and I I just we're
we're headed towards something here we
we are and I I worry about what these
officials that they're trying to do a
job that is almost impossible to be
perfect uh how big of a concern should
that
be I think it's I think it should be a
very big concern and you said it they're
trying to be perfect and that's the
standard for officiating we we we are
less we're less accepting of a missed
call as we are you know a drop pass or a
missed block or or a wrong call on
fourth down going forward or not and no
one's perfect they can never reach that
standard and you hit the nail on the
head with gambling because 25 years ago
right the NFL didn't have to worry about
gambling right that's illegal that's not
part of now it's legal now the NFL you
can't watch a game without seeing these
gambling ads the betting ads we're
playing the Super Bowl in Las Vegas
we've got a team in Las Vegas which 20
years ago you would have I would have
never even guessed that so you
absolutely have to worry about these
things and you have to give the
officials better Direction make sure we
can get the calls on the field correct
mitigate mistakes and also use
technology I feel like we're using
technology in some areas where it's
probably not as important we're moving
the ball yard here maybe maybe taking a
couple seconds off the clock in the
third quarter but let's get the big
plays right let's mitigate those game
changing mistakes I also wonder when you
spoke to officials it's almost like I
can throw a flag and I can pick it up
therefore I can kind of protect myself
you're asking for the home office to
give you some help in the moment with
these
calls are we going to get to the point
where everything is reviewed like
getting the call right is that's
Paramount here it it is Paramount but I
think it's a balance I don't think we
can reffi every play there's just two
there's 153 154 plays in the game
there's there
seven officials they're making all of
them are making decisions before the
play during the play and after the play
there's thousands of decisions that are
being made and the overwhelming majority
are correct but to Rea aate every play
and replay the game would just it would
it would have no flow no momentum so I
think you've got to find that balance
there's four or five plays in a game
that decide a game and we have to be
perfect on those four or five and manage
the rest of the game mitigate mistakes
and I think that's kind of that that
that middle ground that that the NFL has
to find and I know people talk about
full-time refs I I don't know well tell
me the difference if you're part-time uh
referee or you're full-time referee how
does that change how you call a game how
accurate you are how much better are you
I don't I don't know if it it's hard to
quantify right if the if the officials
are 95% accurate now there's making them
full-time make them 98% accurate it's
impossible they're never going to be
100% accurate they are as full-time as
they can be during the season right
football's different than basketball and
baseball and hockey you don't have
multiple games each week you know
baseball Baseball umpires aren't when
they're working the games they're
assigned but on their off days during
the season it's not like they're at
practice with the with the Dodgers or
the angels and they're and they're and
they're practicing their calls at first
base or or or strike ball counts things
like that so you have to find some
things in the offseason for officials to
do you know I think there's an
opportunity there but just making them
full-time or calling them full-time I
don't think that solves anything they're
still they're still human beings that
are officiating a game that is played by
tremendous athletes and you just have to
continue to work to get them better get
them on the same page I'm not saying
there aren't opportunities for them to
do more especially in the off season but
I don't know if just calling them
full-time is going to make a big
difference and I tell people if you ever
get the opportunity to be on the
sidelines of an NFL game and look at a
bang bang play like the speed is what
you know jumps out at you when we watch
on TV we're like how could they miss
that well when you're on the field and
you're going was that pass inter it
certainly looked like pass interference
or that couldn't have been pass it's
right in front of you and I I still
couldn't make a call like that the speed
is what really stands out it's exactly
right and and standing on the sideline
and and there's that disconnect because
you stand on the sideline and you watch
that bang bang play
and you go how do they ever get anything
right and then you and then you and then
you watch it right how do we get to
evaluate the official gets to see it
once full speed from from their
perspective and we get to evaluate them
and critique them from five different
slow motion angles and oh here's the
reverse angle and here's the low end
zone shot and we go how did they miss
that and there's that disconnect and and
and and I get it because we're not down
on the field we're not watching the game
but sometimes we're putting the
officials in an impossible and
impossible spot because we're evaluating
them to a standard that the human being
can't reach always great to talk to you
and uh thanks for joining us thanks for
dumbing dumbing down this information so
I could understand it Dean thank you you
got it Dan Dean blandino Fox NFL rules
analyst former NFL VP of officiating he
is working the Chiefs Patriots bills in
the Cowboys game where he gets to
monitor that and then they go Dean what
did you see on that play and then he
gets to tell you what he saw